thank you for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show Brian is with us at
Davenport Iowa
hi Brian how are you wonderful how are
you better than I deserve sir how kind
of help well I've been listening to the
podcast for about four months and really
soaking it in and read a lot of Total
Money Makeover and I'm on board 100%
we're on step two and working our way
you know through that and that's going
well my wife is sort of on board by
proxy she hasn't listened to read or
anything okay she's she's just sort of
following my lead and um which is great
but there's one struggle that we have
she has these and I'm on board with you
know don't have credit cards but she has
these store cards you know these they're
not visas and mastercards but they're
store art and and you know she doesn't
want to get rid of them because they
send her coupons if she does if she uses
them are they or she gets points and and
you know I dutifully pay them down to
zero every month that that's not a
problem but I hate them they complicate
my life and it's just more things to
keep track of but I don't know how to
how to explain to her in a sort of a
loving way that you know we need to get
rid of them I don't want to just cut
them up and and just sort of no no no
that would be bad I'll go ahead or I
might regret yeah better I want I want
her to be in agreement I don't know how
to explain it to her okay
so let's kind of get down under this for
a second what the real problem is is
that she trusted you till he got to her
cards the proxy ended at the department
store cards right right so what this is
saying is you all are evolving through
this process which is kind of normal and
the next step in the evolution the
process is not proxy anymore it's
instead of her trusting you for her to
gather together the same information
you've been gathering
say the goal is not to fur hair to get
rid of cards the goal is for her to
learn some of the things that you have
learned that you've got excited about
right and when she learns those things
whether it's podcast whether it's just a
totally makeover book or something else
then she will be as excited as you are
and it won't be by proxy and so this has
gone as far as it's going to go with
proxy okay you'll put this thing into oh
this whole movement into overdrive when
she actually gets the Y and the Y is not
because I trust my husband it's great
that she does trust you that's very cool
but that's not know ye anymore the wine
ounce needs to be that she grasped why
you're doing this have you guys been
through Financial Peace University no
would she go if I gave it to you yeah I
think so
I'll give it yeah if she would chew it
I'll pay for it the two you need to go
because if the two of you go to class
and go honey just do me a favor just let
go this class with me it's only nine
times and then we'll talk about this
other stuff because she's going to go
the lightbulbs going to come on over her
head she's not unwilling she's not
unintelligent she's not a princess she
just said oh honey whatever you want to
do until you wanted to mess with her
stuff and then whatever you want to do
didn't cut it now she's now she's
wanting to be a thinking person and
engage in the process so she's an easy
one she's an easy person to convert
because she's not adversarial write it
now if you push her and make my name
into a cuss word by just yak at her all
the time about this stuff you'll make it
adversarial don't do that that is what
I'm afraid of yeah instead you guys just
go to the class and I'll pay for it and
just say as little as you can possibly
say but enough to get her to go with you
okay maybe proxy will extend enough to
get her to go to class on proxy that
would be fine cuz then she's going to
get a hold of it and she's going to go
oh now I see what you're saying Brian
all right let's do this game on baby
that's what's going to have this lady
because that's who this lady is isn't
yeah yeah cool very cool
hang on I'll have Zach pickup and we'll
get you guys into a class hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]